this weekend's king of coachella harry  styles and the duet no one saw coming  [Music]  yep harry invited his childhood idol  shania twain to the stage for a surprise  performance  [Music]  in the car  with my mother as a child  this lady taught me to sing  she also told me that men are trash  but  to you  the memories you gave me with my mother  i will be forever grateful it's a dream  come true for harry who told us almost  five years ago how much the country star  means to him i think both music and  fashion main influence was  was probably shania twain  um  yeah i just think she's great he's just  a really cool  person  and awesome singer and yeah i mean  that's a huge compliment to me i'm kind  of lost for words i'm a bit starstruck  what can i say  he is very stylish i mean forget about  the pun he's an elegant guy harry's  real-life love olivia wilde was spotted  in the crowd along with stars like james  corden heidi klum and jared leto  [Music]  you